[Music]
hey I need help with my abs your apps I
don't see why you can't do this yourself
that is Springs Nicholas to your
genitals sir
[Music]
Hoss go brush money and welcome to I
don't know just just promise me that you
lock the door behind you and you watch
this with headphones that's that's all I
ask
what's interesting about this game is
that it can only be played during
certain times so I waited like a
[ __ ] to play this game and
you'll see that it's pretty pathetic
that I've waited to play this game but
I'm really really excited about it
and I think it's six now so this should
be correct on one hour too early
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's starting my witness
saw it for this this is so sad
okay I'm in the shower all alone thank
you ah ah mother oh there are their
people
[Music]
I enjoy it share it with my friends
nothing weird with that we all shower
every day every day we shower don't you
shower every day
whoa whoa yes I should not be excited
but I waited so long oh my god I'm so
happy I've never been this happy to see
you naked bang hey bro hey he called me
bro
[Music]
okay hey bro that was a tough workout
wasn't it huh yes I like how many
showers with sunglasses yo can you get
my back
what's that sure bro hey I'm willing
[ __ ] so sorry
oh okay oh this feels strangely right oh
did you blind you locked your door now
say I told you bro you're so tense Pro
oh yeah yeah like you got it you gotta
relax bro just just let me take care of
you you're fine now guy hope that I am
working that [ __ ] for you huh yes real
good man yeah let's high-five how many
percent eighty six percent that's great
Wow oh thank you he called me pal best
game who'd you get my pick oh my god it
doesn't end it keeps going hey kids go
ahead and love rubbing your nipples bro
those are mechanist I'm not gonna stop
[Music]
feel so safe one of you don't please
don't say that 90% - I know I can trust
you
yo dude I need some love on my pits on
your pits oh ok if you're unfit you know
it has left but it's just you and me now
ah you know your face is not that way -
Raj I could rub our pits hey I need help
with my ABS your ass I don't see why you
can't do this yourself that is strange
Nicholas to your genitals sir but I have
never said no to Romanies oh I could do
this all day all day all day every day
all day every day
Oh feels so knowledge a are they disco
lights in the shower this is my favorite
shower of all times I generated this
shower and a shower we have something
special
98% what did you never go Briscoe safe
when I'm with you uh glad you feel that
way Brown fight see you around
smell you later maybe next time we can
do more now yeah don't leave me
nah 8 hours and 50 minutes are you
kidding me
well I'm gonna wait hey I need some love
on my ass
[Music]
[Applause]
that's it I'm done
[Music]
so let's play a horror game to spice it
up a little bit it's been a while okay
well here we are this is how anyone
works everyone watch like this I'm a DJ
can't wait to scratch those tables this
is actually really creepy
I like the Gameboy a graphic atmosphere
it makes me feel good going downstairs I
can't it's not God Oh God this is creepy
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Chet Chet Chet chip
that [ __ ] is that
oh Jesus we're fine it was just a face
what do we got here
[ __ ] you barrel [ __ ] you know oh my god
it's a television that's creepy
[ __ ] yeah Dahlia [ __ ] god damn this is
so weird and creepy
that's a [ __ ] sound I'm good [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you huh oh it goes slower
when I flip them off god damn those
terrifying oh my god
no no [ __ ] you man [ __ ] animate oh
god that sound not a big fan of that
sound what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
they weren't oh my god I had the ability
of [ __ ] people off Oh could this be
it
[ __ ] Oh God oh [ __ ] it's a skeleton
[ __ ] you making my way downtown I can't
I can't it's I know I'm a [ __ ] I just
can't I don't want to play it anymore
I'm sorry I'm busy what do you want
[Music]
let's play something nicer and light all
right
today has been emotional to say the
least no breaks Mellie I think the cars
keeps coming you cannot break Oh God
okay alright yeah those bad oh [ __ ] gosh
oh oh [ __ ]
I mean the man Hey alright this will be
a good party nice parking doing Hayes
our money down there I want the money
bottom bottom I know my nail then oh god
it's a prime minister never got fired
there no part [ __ ] teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle car hey I'll take it
alright today has been an adventure to
say the least
I feel not okay like I wanna sleep
someone ask me right now Oh was that
not okay not okay thank you for so much
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one say awesome race
PewDiePie simulator being PewDiePie
I can't wait to jump in I always wanted
to know what it's like to be purified so
ah here we are this is myself
that's actually my tape Maya what are
you doing that